En qué se centra el choque entre los
gobiernos de Estados Unidos y China
sobre el tema de Taiwán
Bueno yo digo que lamentablemente el
tema de Taiwán está en el epicentro hoy
este conflicto más que nada por la
agenda que están impulsando los
demócratas que desde que asumió en en la
casa blanca han puesto esta cuestión y
han empezado a escalar las provocaciones
en este caso lo más controversial es la
posible visita de Nancy pelosia Taiwán
que llevaría a la cuestión a un límite
hasta ahora digamos que no no había no
sabía superado
eso fue parte de la conversación una
conversación que podría haber estado
centrada en otros temas mucho más
relevantes que hacen a la competencia y
a la cooperación Pero bueno obviamente
este tema por la lo delicado que es para
china estuvo en el centro de la de la
conversación y hubo advertencias muy
fuertes por parte del presidente Sí y el
presidente Valle de alguna manera trató
de bajar los decibeles Pese a que la
cuestión está ahí candente
Bueno y qué significa puntualmente Esta
visita de Nancy pelosi a la isla el
próximo mes puede considerarse una
especie de provocación
absolutamente es una provocación abierta
desde el punto de vista de la diplomacia
estadounidense no se entiende bien cuál
sería el objetivo Más allá de molestar a
Beijing en este momento tan complejo con
la guerra en Ucrania con la pandemia con
la recesión económica muchas cuestiones
que son que es muy necesario que estas
dos potencias trabajen logren algún tipo
de acuerdo que entiendo que eso se sigue
trabajando por otros canales Pero esto
obviamente es una provocación que frena
y un montón de otras cosas y genera muy
mal clima para que se pueda prosperar en
esas cuestiones críticas que ganan los
demócratas con Esta visita nada o sea es
muy difícil realmente ver un resultado
positivo para los Estados Unidos con
esto
y Qué consecuencias entonces Podría
tener Esta visita porque como usted lo
mencionaba Beijing ya habló de sanciones
A qué se puede referir el gobierno chino
bueno es difícil pensar en sanciones no
en el marco de una guerra comercial que
ya está desatado uno puede imaginarse
que en lugar de seguir avanzando en la
línea de la suspensión de las tarifas
que es un preacuerdo que se había
logrado quizás china Ahora vuelvo a
imponer sanciones Y eso se frene pero el
presidente Sí fue enfático al decir que
esto es jugar con fuego al hablar de
fuego uno tiende a pensar quizás en
algún tipo de
réplica que tenga que ver con lo militar
en paralelo casualmente los Estados
Unidos movilizaron un portaaviones con
un cuerpo también de parte de la flota
del Pacífico se entiende que eso tendría
que ver con la posible visita de pelosi
bueno esperemos que eso en otra Hacienda
de lo de lo económico en términos de
sanciones y que no pasemos esa delgada
línea Roja en lo militar que todo el
tiempo estamos ahí en veremos si esto
efectivamente puede suceder hasta ahora
no y esperemos que esto continúe de esa
forma